MORNING BANG THE GAVEL GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME. TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND FACE
COVERINGS OUTLINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT WILL
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE. INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. ALL
INDIVIDUALS TO PER FOR COMMENT
TO PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEES WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO I'LL REPEAT THAT.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE OH TWO ONE
EIGHT ONE THREE. THREE OH TWO
ONE EIGHT ONE THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT- THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND
YOU WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ALL REMEMBER ONCE
YOU'RE CALLED UPON. MUTE THE
PHONE THAT YOU'RE WATCHING OR
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARINGS. OBVIOUSLY ALL TRY TO
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HOW THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY A RE LITIGATING THE
POLICY MERITS. OF A BILL WE'RE
FOCUSED ON THE FISCAL IN THIS
COMMITTEE. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MATTERS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE PATIENT
AND RESPECTFUL SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN HAVE
THEIR VOICES HEARD. WE HAVE-
FIFTY THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA- ONE ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR TO PASS A MOTION. AND THE
REST. ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES- SB FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WILL BE PULLED FROM THE
J. AND REESE. FOR THE MAY THIRD.
OF FINANCE NOTIFIED THE
COMMITTEE THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
FILES OR COMMENTS FOR ANY OF
THE BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
SO THE REPRESENTATIVE WILL BE
HERE WILL NOT BE PARTICIPATING
TODAY. BEFORE WE YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. IS
TO CONSULT WITH YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE SENATOR BATES.
BATES HERE CENTER BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE JONES PALM LAGER
KAMLAGER HERE CENTER LAYER. AND
CENTER LIKE ASKING YOUR CASKET
HERE WE HAVE MEMBERS PRESENT WE
HAVE A QUORUM OF WE'RE GOING
START MOVING NOW WILL MOVE TO
THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY. DUE TO
THIS CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'LL BE INSTITUTING A
TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED-
THREE MINUTES OF TOTAL TIME FOR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY WILL LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION IF
NECESSARY WILL ALSO LIMIT THE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY TO TWELVE
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE. AS A
REMINDER ALL WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY. OBVIOUSLY I'M
GONNA STICK TO THE ME TOO
STRICTLY TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY.
ON THE SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES
BEYOND THE- PRIMARY WITNESSES.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR FIRST
BILL WHICH IS S. B. ONE BY
SENATOR ATKINS ON COASTAL
RESOURCE C. LEVEL RISE THIS IS
A SUSPENSE. CANDIDATE AND
SENATOR ATKINS HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION- IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM IN FAVOR.
OF THE FORTY TWO OH THREE I SEE
ABSOLUTELY NO ONE HERE- AND
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE- SO NOW
WILL MOVE TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE TELECONFERENCE I
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS. WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE.
YES SIR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OF SB ONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU'LL HAVE BEEN EIGHTEEN
TEAM OF SPECIALISTS PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND WE
WILL CALL YOUR LINE WHEN IT-
WHEN YOU ARE READY. AGAIN PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE A- SOME CHEWING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SIX QUID. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUST MY REFUSAL
COMBINED READERSHIP GROUP WE
HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED OUR LETTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME SIR.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB. ONE- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SEEING NONE.
NOBODY IN THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE HE
WANTS TO OPPOSE SB ONE. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE A LINE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER. REAL GOOD
LINE TWELVE GO AHEAD PLEASE-
HELLO IS THIS LINE TWELVE. LINE
TWELVE THAT MY N. COMMITTEE.
YES YOU ARE YES YOU ARE GO
AHEAD PLEASE S. B. WE'RE ON S.
GREAT YOU CAN HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN SB ONE IS THAT RIGHT ATKINS
COASTAL RESOURCES PLEASE TELL
US YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION. AM I IN THE
RIGHT COMMITTEE THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS SO CONFUSING AND O'DONNELL
LOVES TO CUT PEOPLE OFF AND
LORENA GONZALEZ LEADS TO CUT
PEOPLE OFF AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I'M ON THE RIGHT
PLACE IS THIS APPROPRIATIONS
AND THE SENATE IS THIS
PORTANTINO DO YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. MA'AM IF YOU DON'T
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION
WE ARE GOING TO CUT YOU OFF. MY
NAME IS I DON'T KNOW IF I'M IN
THE RIGHT PLACE AT MY IN THE
RIGHT PLACES THIS
APPROPRIATIONS I'M CALLING
ABOUT SB ONE COASTAL RESOURCES
THE AUTHORS ATKINS HI THERE MY
IN THE RIGHT PLACE. BECAUSE
YOUR PHONE SYSTEMS DON'T WORK
AND YOU CUT CALIFORNIANS BOX
AND WE WOULDN'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN WHAT WE YES WHAT MA'AM
WE ARE GOING TO CUT YOU OFF
THANK. YOU WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. AT THIS TIME. THANK MR
MODERATOR- SHOULD TAKE A OF THE
OP THAT HAVE TO SPEAK ON THE
BILL WHEN GRANT THE OP- WHICH
WE PUBLIC COMMENT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE CONFIRM THAT
WE WERE IN THE RIGHT PLACE AND
SO WE'RE MOVING ON- WE'VE NOW
HEARD FROM- OF FOLKS WHO HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BOTH FOR AND AGAINST THE BILL
WILL COME BACK TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO HANDS
GOING UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB ONE WILL BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. WE'RE NOT GONNA
MOVE TO S. B. TWENTY TWO- BY
SENATOR GLAZERS THIS ITEM IS ON
PUBLIC PRESCHOOL K. TWELVE AND
COLLEGE HEALTH AND SAFETY BOND
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY TWO- IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. PRESENT OKAY NOBODY IN
ROOM FOR TWO- THREE NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP WITNESSES WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
TWO THIS IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU INTENT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE ONE LINE CHEWED
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
BUT WHAT A LINE TWENTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. ONE POINT TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JUST HIGHER AGAIN WITH
WITH A COMBINED LEADERSHIP
GROUP WILL PROBABLY SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL MOVE NOW TO LINE TWENTY
THREE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FIND
TWENTY THREE YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JENNIFER BAKER WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITY COALITION WITH
THE SUPPORT OF COMMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THIS
IS PORTANTINO THIS IS S. B.
TWENTY TWO. WE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE
THIRTY ONE IS THIS- SB TWENTY
TWO GLAZER. YES IT IS. AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
YOU SPENDING FIFTEEN BILLION OF
CALIFORNIANS DOLLARS ON A BOND
WHEN SCHOOL HAS BEEN MOVED TO
VIRTUAL AND YOU SHOULDN'T CUT
CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO SPEAK THEIR OPINION
ON LEGISLATION MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD. THANK YOU. STRONG
OPPOSITE. TWENTY TWO THIRDS YOU
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THEIR PLEASE.
OF OUR DAY WE YOU HAVE A RALLY
CHILLED MODERATOR. THANK YOU
AGAIN. THERE'S I'M NOT. OUR
MISTER MODERATORS ARE A OTHERS
FOR SB TWO TWO SHE BILL. WE ARE
GOING TO LISTEN TO THIS ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO OPT OF
SB TWO TWO- THERE'S NO IN ROOM
TWO- THREE THERE'S NO AROUND
TWENTY FORTY- MISTER MODERATE
ANY OP SB TWENTY TWO- OTHER
THAN THE ONE CALL WE'VE ALREADY
HAD- WHO. WE HAVE- LINE THIRTY
ONE QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BY THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL I'M THIRTY ONE ISN'T IT
FUNNY I'LL REITERATE WHAT I
JUST SAID FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS RIGHT NOW YOU'RE GOING
TO THROW. THANK YOU. THIS YEAR
YOU MAY MOVE OUT. ALL RIGHT-
WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION- AND
WE'LL COME BACK TO COMMITTEE. I
SEE NO CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWENTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON SB FOUR
FOUR SIX. ALSO BY SENATOR
GLAZER- THIS BILL DEALS WITH
FACTUAL INNOCENCE- AND MR WE
WILL GO TO FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT MR MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FOUR FOUR SIX. AND A FEW
OF LIKE TO OF. BUTCHERS PRESS
BE FORCE PLEASE ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE THE
PROVIDER LINE NUMBER. WE WILL
GO ONLINE THIRTY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. FIVE THIRTY THREE- LINE
IS OPEN. SEVERAL THEMSELVES
FROM Q. YOU MAY PROCEED ALL
RIGHT WE ABOUT OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY SUPPORT PRESS. FOR
SIX OBLIGATION BROKE
ADDITIONALLY EN ROUTE FOR TWO-
THREE. THERE'S NO IN THE ROOM
FOR FORTY IN THE MICRO MISTER
MODERATOR YOU COULD QUEUE UP
OPPOSITE THIS BEFORE. SIX IT
THURSDAY WAS SPEAKING UP AS OF
THE FOUR FLOORS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO THIS TIME.
FISH
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES I
AM I'M SORRY AGAIN WITH YOU-
YEAH IF YOU ARE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I WILL OPEN LINE THIRTY
ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. WHY IN
THIRTY ONE I JUST WON'T GO AWAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS
THAT YOU TURNED A HUNDRED
PEOPLE AWAY LAST WEEK FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THAT
BUILDING IS STILL QUOTE. VIRUS
WITH A NINETY NINE POINT 9%
YOUR MODERATOR THANK YOU.NOT
RETURN BACK WHEN. PHONE
RESOURCE. FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
THIS NOT THE JUDICIARY THIS IS
NOT NATURAL RESOURCES THIS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND WE
DID NOT TURN A HUNDRED PEOPLE
AWAY. SO WE WILL WE MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. TO S. B. FOUR FOUR
SIX. HELLO WHAT ELSE AND GIVE
US A CURRENT ALL RIGHT HAVE A
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME.
AND OPPOSITION AND THAT'S
BEFORE FOUR SIX AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE FOR
SIX. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB FIVE FORTY SEVEN BY
MISTER GLAZER ON CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY EMERGENCY TEAM
PROGRAMS- WE WILL STAY OPEN UP
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. AND THERE'S NO IN
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
FOUR SEVEN. ONE ONE THIRTY ONE
BECAUSE- IT BEACON SUPPORT OF
THE- TO SPEAK UP IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PLEASED ONE ZERO THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO INCLUDING UP TO JEER
GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPT OF A FIVE FORTY SO
THERE'S NO IN ROOM- FORTY TWO
OF. NOBODY IN ROOM TO. FIVE
MOST MODERATE ARE AN CAN UP.
ENOUGH OF. FIVE FOUR SEVEN. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO IN UP OF SB
FIVE FOUR SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU SEE TAKE
THIS VETERINARIAN PURCHASING.
WEARABLE LINE THIRTY ONE IN Q.
BUT PLEASE. ONE THIRTY ONE AND
I'M NOT AAY BECAUSE THIS IS
NONSENSE YOU PEOPLE NEED TO
OPEN THE BUILDING YOU SHOULD BE
LEGISLATING ANYTHING YOU SHOULD
NOT BE TURNING CALIFORNIAN THE
WAY WHO ARE TRYING TO BE
INVOLVED THANK YOU. YEAH AND WE
ARE ON SB FIVE FORTY SEVEN-
WHICH IS ON CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY EMERGENCY PROGRAMS
AND- WE ARE ON SUPPORT SHE WAS
OR ANYONE ELSE. IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT. AT THURSDAY'S FOR THIS
MAGICALLY PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE KNOWING QUEUED UP OF THIS
TIMES GO AHEAD PRAYER WILL DROP
AS SB FIVE FORTY SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE
FOUR SEVEN. SPEAKING OF. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THIS TIME.
WELL KNOWN IN CUBA GERMAN
PLEASE AHEAD R. I. HAVING FILE
HAVING THE UP FOR THE TO SPEAK
IN FOR AND A POP IN SEEING NO
GO WITH THAT OBJECTION SB FIVE
FOUR SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO SUSPEND
MOVIE M. S. SEVEN FORTY NINE BY
MISTER GLAZER ON MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM OVERSIGHT- THERE IS TO
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING FOR
SUPPORT FOR THEIR COMPANY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE- THERE IS
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
AND MISS MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
SEVEN FORTY NINE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FORTY NINE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN ALL
RIGHT WELL NOW THAT OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN FORTY NINE AND WILL
GIVE THE OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. S.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FORTY
NINE. IT IS BEACON OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO INCLUDING UP OKAY
HAVING TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND SB
FORTY NINE. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
FORTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
BY MISTER GLAZER ON CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM AT THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. WE
WILL OPEN UP A PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THIS MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
AT THIS TIME. ENTERS BEACONS OF
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO IN Q. MISTER SHERMAN. ALL
RIGHT WE WITHOUT OPPOSITION ON
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM- THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MYSTERON RAIDER PLEASE Q. D.
TESTIMONY. ON SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIV OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IT
IS BIG OPPOSITE OF THIS SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE PRESS ONE THEN AT
THIS TIME. I MEAN. IRAN IS.
YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN WHERE
GOING TO ADD UP ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFF THE FOR THE AND UP
AND SEEING NO GO UP FOR THAT OF
S. B. C. EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO
TO. FOR THE RECORD- ALL OF THE
AUTHORS THIS HAVE PRESENT SIDE
WANNA MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR ON
THAT AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO SB
SEVEN NINETY TWO ALSO BY
SENATOR GLAZERS AND HE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION AS WELL ON THIS
BILL AND THIS I ON SALES USE
TAX RETAILER REPORTING AND WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR SUPPORT SEEING NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE AND
SUPPORT. THING NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT.
FOR SB. SEVEN NINETY TWO. IT IS
BECAUSE OF PLEASED ONE THE ZERO
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO INCLUDING AT THIS TIME
YOU MAY PROCEED ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION THAT'S NOW THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE OPPOSED
SB SEVEN NINETY TWO TO SPEAK
AND THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ESTRADA RAIDER PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE OPPOSITION FOUR SB. SEVEN
NINETY TWO. IT IS BIG IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN NINETY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUED UP TO
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SB SEVEN NINETY
TWO AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ONTO SENATOR HER TADO. SB
FORTY ON HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AT CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL SCHOLARS PROGRAM. WE
WILL OPEN A PUBLIC HEARING
FINANCIALLY IS WAY PRESENTATION
ON ALL FOUR FOR BILLS TODAY-
WITCHER SUSPENSE CANDIDATES- WE
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING.
SEEING KNOWN A ROOM FORTY TWO
OF. FEMALE IN ROOM TWENTY- WE
WILL TO THE PHONE LINE FOR. OF
S. FOUR. IF THERE IS A SPEAKING
IS OF BEFORE PRESS ONE THE ZERO
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE THE WINNING CARE. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL DROP. SB FORTY
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
THERE'S NO EN ROUTE. TWENTY
PLEASE Q. OF ANYONE WITH TO
APPLY SB FORTY AT THIS TIME.
SPEAKING OPPOSITE OF S. FORTY
PRESS THEN TO TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SB FORTY
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FORTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. OF IN SB ONE HUNDRED
BY SENATOR TODD ON FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM WORKING GROUP- SHE'S
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIFY MONEY IN
SUPPORT TO OPEN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY. YEARS NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
ONE HUNDRED EXCUSE ME. SB ONE
HUNDRED. BAKER YOU'RE SPEAKING
AS A OF THIS ONE ON PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THERE SEEMS TO BE A CO ABOUT
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO
TESTIFY ON SB FORTY DID WE MISS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE FOLKS IN
THE Q. ONE SB FORTY. I DID NOT
SHOW ANYONE IN Q. LET ME DOUBLE
CHECK WITH BLACK. I MEAN TOLD
BY OUR CALLS. UP THERE WITH
PEOPLE. BACK. ALL RIGHT WE ARE
ON SB ONE HUNDRED RIGHT NOW
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT RIGHT.
SO IF YOU CAN'T FIND THE SB
FORTY FOLKS APOLOGIZE IF HE GOT
CAUGHT IN ANY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY IF YOU MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. WE WILL
COURSE BE OPEN TO YOUR WRITTEN
COMMENTS SO DON'T HESITATE TO
SEND YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE. AND WE'RE GONNA
GO BACK TO SB ONE HUNDRED WE
JUST FOR THE SAKE OF- SINCE WE
GOT A LITTLE BIT OUT OF. WHACK
MISTER MODERATOR IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE HUNDRED. SENATOR TADO
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM WORKING
GROUP'S. SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE
FOR SB ONE HUNDRED. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE- I DID- FIND SOME
LINES THAT IT QUEUED UP AND I
DO APOLOGIZE THERE ARE. PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN QUEUE NOW AND
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THEY'RE IN QUEUE FOR
THE- I WILL OPEN IT UP FOR THEM
TO. TAKE TESTIFY ON EITHER SB
FORTY OR SB ONE HUNDRED SINCE
WE DON'T KNOW. AND WE'LL ALL BE
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. HAVE TO MAKE
WORKING GROUP IS WHAT I. THE
FACT YOU'RE SPEAKING FOR IN THE
WORLD. THIS LIKE A PRO. PEOPLE.
BUT SOMEBODY SCRATCHING YOU
PEOPLE OPENED HIS. JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE WILL. PROVIDE
THEIR LINE RIGHT NOW AND I DO
APOLOGIZE WE. ROSS PEROT.
PHILOSOPHY WILL GO TO LINE FOR.
GO AHEAD PLEASE. WELL NAME IS
ARIANNA CENTER ON INTO OF S.
FOUR- ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICINE AND MARK AFTER EDUCATE
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU. ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO BUCKS.
WHAT WILL PLEASE. OKAY. WILL
MOVE NEXT TO LINE THIRTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS DANIEL
PELLEGRINI- I'M A PHYSICIAN
WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A AND A
BOARD MEMBER FOR CALIFORNIA
MEDICINE I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF. THE FORTY- WE THINK
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT- AS BOTH
A- EQUITY MEASURE AND MORE IN
SO FAR AS THE ENHANCEMENT OF
CARE DELIVERY WITH THE- WITH
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SO- THANK YOU DR I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THAT IMPORTANCE THANK YOU. I
WILL GO NEXT TO LINE FORTY
THREE. AND IF PLAN FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN BAKER SKI
THANK YOU THE MORNING AIR
NAVARRO WITH THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU I WAS GONNA SAY PEOPLE
CONFINE THEMSELVES TO THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION I'D APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. AND THE BILL NUMBER.
THE SERVICE. WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BORDERLINE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING KIDNEY
BAN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATE OUR POSITION OR CAL
COSTA IN SUPPORT AT THE ONE
HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WOOD
LINE THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ACTUALLY THESE LINES ARE NOT Q.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SB
FORTY ON A NUMEROUS OCCASIONS
AND CORRECTED OUR TECHNICAL
ISSUES WE'RE MOVING BACK TO SB
ONE HUNDRED SO ONE LAST
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT OF SB
ONE HUNDRED. MISTER MODERATOR.
IS BEACON SUPPORT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE HUNDRED PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION SB ONE HUNDRED ART
HER TADO ON FOSTER CARE PROGRAM
WORKING GROUP- THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE OPPOSED SB.
ONE HUNDRED. FIGURE OPPOSED TO
SP ONE HUNDRED THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE LINE THIRTY ONE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. YOU HAVE
CALIFORNIANS ON THE LINE I AM
COMMUNICATING WITH FRIENDS WHO
CANNOT GET A LINE TO SPEAK
THROUGH YOU NEED TO REVISIT
THIS. THANK NOBODY THIS
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE PEOPLE
CANNOT THANK YOU. SIR ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO BUY IN
OPPOSITION YES WE DO A HUNDRED.
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE LINE IN Q.
THAT IS LINE THIRTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES I'M CALLING
AN APPLE OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
HUNDRED OF THE PRIVATE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
BUT ANYONE ELSE SUPPOSED TO BE
ABILITY UNDER. I WAS GOING TO
LISTEN TO THIS TIME SIR ALL
RIGHT WE OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ONE HUNDRED AND SEEING NO HANDS
MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ONE HUNDRED WILL.
GO TO SUSPENSE. MY COLLEAGUES
ON THIS WE'RE ALL HAVING FUN
THIS MORNING BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO KEEP. SETTING A GOOD
EXAMPLE. LET'S KEEP MOVING ON
SB THREE NINETY THREE. I WAS
LOOKING AT YOU LATER DEAR THE
TROUBLEMAKER. THAT'S ONE OF THE
MOST ENCOURAGING COMMENTS I'VE
HAD THIS MORNING. ALL RIGHT- WE
ARE MOVING ON SB THREE NINETY
THREE FROM SENATOR HER TADO ON
MIGRANT CHILDREN AND
DEVELOPMENT- SEE OPPORTUNITY
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR SUPPORT AND I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY
THREE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE NINETY THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TAKE
WHERE. WE- LOAD COMING UP AT
THIS TIME YOU MAY BE SEATED
MISTER RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT WILL MOVED OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE OPPOSED SB THREE
NINETY THREE THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I'M INTO THE
MICROPHONE MYSTERON RATED
PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. THREE NINE
THREE. SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE NINETY THREE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
GO TO LIVE THIRTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES I'M CALLING
IN MY OPPOSITION FOR SB THREE
NINETY THREE OF THE PRIVATE IT
HAS BEEN A CALIFORNIA. WHAT'S
YOUR NAME IF YOU WANT TO. GIVE
US YOUR NAME NOW OKAY. NEXT
PERSON. THE TONIGHT WE HAVE NO
NO SINCE YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVE AN OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION SB THREE NINETY
THREE AND SEEING NO HANDS ARE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE NINE
THREE. HAS MOVED TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO MISTER TADAS LAST
PHYLLIS BEFORE FIVE THREE SHE'S
WAY PRESENTATION AS HE DID ON
THE THREE PREVIOUS BILLS. THIS
IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
TESTIMONY AND I SEE NO WILL
OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY REPORTED TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY S. MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE ON THE LINE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE SHOULD MAKE FOR FIFTY
THREE. AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CAN. LOW QUEUED UP
MR GERMAN ALL I WILL NOT
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE ON AGRICULTURAL
BIOSECURITY AND EMERGENCY
INFECTIOUS DISEASES- THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION S. B. FOUR FIFTY
THREE A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. IF
YOU'RE SPEAKING IN THE
OPPOSITION OF S. B. OR FIFTY
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HELLO AGAIN TO LINE
THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES I'M CALLING AGAIN ABOUT AS
THE FOUR FIFTY THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND ADDS MEMBER
OF AN AGRICULTURAL FAMILY.
THANK YOU. OKAY CLOSER. TO
HELLO NELSON Q. THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVE AN OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE FIFTY
THREE IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOUR FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUCCESS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO MR
MOANS FOR BILLS STARTING WITH
SB FORTY SEVENS ON OIL AND GAS
HAZARDOUS AND IDLE DESERTED
WELLS. AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND SHE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION ON ALL FOUR FOR
BILLS- MISTER MODERATOR ARCHIE
ME WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING
TO TESTIFY ACTUALLY NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
TESTIFY MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR SUPPORT.
OF SB. FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FORTY SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE A LINE
QUEUING UP ONE LOAD WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE
FOR THE FIRST QUARTER LINE
FORTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
SEAN WALLENSTEIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION VERY
RESPECTFULLY. I'M IN OPPOSITION
TO THE SP FORTY SEVEN I'D LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE YOU ALL YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB UNDER FIRE
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE ARE ON SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
SEVEN AT THIS TIME. ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY SEVEN. WE HAVE NO
AN INTUITIVE TIME SIR ALL RIGHT
WE WILL NEVER OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTY SEVEN THING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM AND SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
ON THE LINE OPPOSED SB. FORTY
SEVEN. AND TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HELLO OPEN UP LINE THIRTY
ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. YOU'RE
DOING WELL UNDER FIRE WHAT IS
SEEN OUR KEY COMMENT AS MOST OF
CALIFORNIA IS LITERALLY ON FIRE
AND YOU PEOPLE ARE LEGISLATING.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM THEIR NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS AGUIAR-CURRY
FROM THE WESTERN CAPE THE
TRAUMA SITUATION WE HAPPENED
OF. THE SHOP AT THE COURT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LAWSUIT YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
TAKING BOTH FOR AN OPPOSED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SB FORTY
SEVEN THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. THING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FORTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
LEVINE SB FIFTY ALSO BY SENATOR
RAMON THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
SB FIFTY THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY ON EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE CENTER THE
MOM. THANK YOU AND AFTER YOU
SPEAK IF YOU WERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY PLUS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BLOODLINE FORTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN AND
GIRLFRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
COULD UP MISTER CHAIRMAN GO
AHEAD PLEASE ALL RIGHT HAVING
OFFER THE SUPPORT OPPORTUNITIES
WILL NOW OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO
SB IFTY. FEMALE IN A ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SAYING NOBODY
IN THE ROOM- TWENTY FORTY- WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY. IF YOU
WERE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIFTY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ON SB
FIFTY AND SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP- SB FIFTY IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
LIVING SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
CEREMONIES WAY PRESENTATION
THIS IS ALSO DISPENSED
CANDIDATE IT IS ON HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DEDUCTIBLES AND OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES. WE WILL OPEN
UP PUBLIC. COMMENT ON SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT. SEEING NO ONE NINE
SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE
SING NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. RUSHING TO THE
MICROPHONE MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT THIS
WOULD BE THE TIME. BAKER ANYONE
IS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
TOTALING THIRTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. MY LINE IS OPEN I'M
CALLING AGAINST SB FIFTY I
TRIED TO GET THROUGH. IN OUR
GARDEN NOT MOVING ON I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND
WHO IS TEACHING. HOW DARE YOU
CENTER CALIFORNIANS VOICE SAYS.
MISTER MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO
LINE THIRTY THANK YOU SIR. WELL
TO ALIGN THIRTY TWO BY A PLACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BUSINESSES PREGNANT WHERE
REPRESENTING THE PHARMACEUTICAL
RESEARCH AND MANUFACTURERS OF
AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF THE
LIMóN BILL THANK YOU. SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT I ASSUME OKAY.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WILL MOVE TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. DIANA
DOUGLAS WHAT HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA SPONSORS OF SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME YOU MAY
PROCEED ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT WE WILL NOT MOVE
TOP POSITION. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
OPPOSE SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
MISTER MODERATOR P. COULD QUEUE
UP THE OPPOSITION. SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT. AND IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO INCLUDE UP TO THE SUN
MISTER CHAIRMAN. ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM THE SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT. GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE AND SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. TIME IS OF THE
MOUNT ON CALIFORNIA STUDENT
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS PROGRAM-
SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
WILL MOVE TO. TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THING NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. THING NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISS
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YEAH WELL IT'S GOT A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR WE HAVE LOADED
UP AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN
YOU MA'AM SEATED ALL RIGHT WILL
DROP OF S. B. SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN- OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. BECAUSE IT IS
BEGIN OPPOSITION SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. A GOOD LINE
THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES I'D LIKE TO SPEAK OUT IN
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN OF THE PRIVATE
CALIFORNIANS TO THE SAN. SANTA
BARBARA THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ELSE INTO THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN AND SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE AS
MENTIONED EARLIER SB FIFTY
EIGHT HAS BEEN MOVED. TO OUR
NEXT HEARING WILL MOVE ON TO SB
SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR TO RAZA ON
EMPLOYMENT AND GARBER FOR
MANUFACTURING. THAT OFFERS YOU
A PRESENTATION AND WE DO HAVE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES ON THE CO
HOST LINE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. MANUELA BOUCHER THEY
LACK CARD DANA FROM CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND AS A RMINDER WE
HAVE THREE MINUTES A TOTAL TIME
FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESSES SO WE
WILL START WITH. MS BUSHEHR DE
LA K. CONTAINER. AND I'M SORRY
I DID NOT DO YOUR NAME JUSTICE
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT AND WE'LL
GO TO OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES. SO
THEY GET THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT. HE DID ESCAPE AT GOOD
MORNING MR MEMBERS. HELLO THIS
YEAR LIKE I AND I ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO BE HERE A CO SPONSOR
AT THE TOP ARE DIRECTLY SIXTY
TWO. SECOND WAGE UP IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY AND WORKERS
I'VE BEEN IN THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER ESTIMATES THAT THE LOW
WAGE INDUSTRIES MCCANDLESS THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY HAS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF WAGE THAT.
APPROXIMATELY NINETY TWO POINT
5% OF GARMENT WORKERS IN LOS
ANGELES AFTER OVERTIME
VIOLATIONS OF ANY GIVEN WEEK
WHICH ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AMOUNTED TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT THREE
MILLION. DOLLARS IN BACK WAGES.
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
WORKERS. RAMPANTLY NOT ONLY
WORKERS BUT THE- AND THE- WHEN
WORKERS MADE ARE STILL. THEIR
TO RECOUP THE LOSSES ARE CLAIMS
THE STATE. I'VE HEARD MANY MANY.
WARRANTY IN LATE AFTER THE PAIR
BEFORE WORK OKAY FILE AND WHEN
THE CLAIM. THE STATE AND LOCAL
THE BACK. AS A RESULT THE
GOVERNMENT WORKER RECIPES FUND
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
THREE AND INTENDED AS OF YOUR
ABOUT YOUR SORT. OF BECOME THE
ONLY SOURCE OF PAYMENT FOR MANY
WORKERS. WHO NEED TO THE
CREATION OF A THOUSAND AN
INCREASE FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
THE STATE. SIDE OF ENTERPRISING
LOCAL BUSINESS PRACTICES
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY SB
SIXTY TWO WOULD RETURN THE
RESTITUTION FINES WHAT STATUS
OF THE PR BOX. OR AND WOULD IN
TURN. TO DATE THE CURRENT OF
THE- LEGISLATIVE OR COMMUNITY.
OR SOMETHING AND- HARLEM. OF
ECONOMY. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE YOUR SUPPORT THAT THE SIXTY
TWO THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO MISTER. SANCHEZ GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER.
CUSTOMERS POLICY OF WHAT'S
AROUND POWER AND WE'RE- TO BE A
CO SPONSOR. SB SIX TWO OF MY
CALL MENTION GROUNDWORK. HOW TO
START THE VICTIM OF SMITH. WAGE
HAS A IN THE INDUSTRY. AS A
RESULT STATE AND GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT. NINE OF DOLLARS IN
TAX REVENUE AND CON. TO
CRITICAL. FOR THIS YEAR A.
RIVER CENTER OF. BUT PUDDLES.
NINE DOLLARS. A THE MOHAWK
COUNTRY TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND. EMPLOYEE
TRAINING FINANCED. OF INSURANCE.
WE SEE ALI CENTER OF ALL LISTED.
THAT THE- IN THE COUNTY LAW
ANGELES THERE'S BEEN AN
ESTIMATE. ONE HUNDRED THREE
MILLION. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE MILLION. DOLLARS ANNUALLY
LAW. LOCAL AND TAX REVENUE.
THANK YOU SO TWO ORCHARD ARE
WORKERS ON A LONG VICTIMS PAGE
THAT WILL DRAW STADIUM LOOK TAX
ARE THANK YOU MISS CHAIRMAN
URGE I WITH THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. ALL RIGHT- HAVING HEARD
THE PRIMER WITNESSES AND OF SB
SIXTY TWO. MR MODERATOR. OF
THAT'S TO FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NO BUT HERE THERE'S NO
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MISTER
MODERATOR FIFTY TWO OF ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY TWO. NOW IS THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU AND IF
THERE WAS ANYONE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. MEASURE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BLOODLINE FORTY FIVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. ONE FORTY FIVE
JUST- YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NOTHING WILL MOVE ON ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO HAVE BY
INTERVIEWING A. BROUGH NEXT TO
LINE FIFTY. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS A BRAND YEAH LEVINE HERE IN
LOS ANGELES- WITH MOST PROBABLY
CALL WE ARE IN STRONG PART OF
THOSE TO BE GREATLY APPRECIATE
DR INTERNET DRUG BILL AND CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE- ONE
MOMENT HERE WHILE WE OPEN UP
THE LINES.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT MISTER MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY TWO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE I'M HAVING OF SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY BEAR WITH
ME ON HOLD. AND. LINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DIVERTING
HUMAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AS YOU REVOLUTION USA
AND GARMENT WORKERS THERE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX DID YOU
AN ADVOCATING FOR GARMENT
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU THEN
NEXT LINE FIFTY THREE LINE IS
OPEN. FROM THAT SENATE LEGAL
SERVICES WE ARE. WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GLOBAL X. LINE FORTY FIVE
BUTTONS.
THIS IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE RESERVE MODERATE THE SLOW
WHEELS OF JUSTICE GOING RIGHT
LOOK ONLINE THIRTY FIVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THE SMALL ONE
MOMENT. HELLO LISTEN TO THIS
TIME MY APOLOGIES- NO PROBLEM
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY TWO OR THE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THING NO ONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SINGLE
IN A ROOM TWENTY FORTIES OR ANY
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE. TO SPEAK
AGAINST SB. SIXTY TWO. AND
SPEAKING OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK.
WE SHOULD GO INTO A UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER SHERMAN NEW MEMBERS
PROCEED HOUSING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY TWO AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIXTY TO GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MR MAGUIRE'S
TO BILLS HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
SB ONE OF FOR A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
HEARING FOR SUPPORT SEEING NO
ONE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE IN
SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT O S.
B. ONE OF FOR MR MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE OH FOUR.
ON ELECTIVE TAX PARTNERSHIP
CORPORATE. S. CORPORATIONS. AT
THIS TIME. IT SPEAKING ABOUT
OPPOSITION S. B. ONE OH FOUR
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME THE PORT. BROWN TO PORT.
BY MR BY MAN IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE WE HAVE NO
INTERIOR OF AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT NOW WILL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ONE OH FOUR
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MISTER MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO IS
OPPOSED S. B. ONE OH FOUR. AND
IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS. OF SB ONE
OF. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE
KNOWING QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION IS B. ONE OH
FOUR AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS B. ONE OH
FOUR. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB TWO OH SIX BY
MISTER MCGUIRE AND FIGHTER
FIGHTER PROCEDURAL BILL OF
RIGHTS SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON SB FORTY TWO OH THREE. IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO OH SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE SHOULD HAVE AN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MISTER MODERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO OH
SIX MAGOR. IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO ZERO SIX
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
LOADS DO NOT. R. I WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO OH
SIX EMAIL ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE IN A ONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MUCH MODERATOR PLEASE
COME ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
OH SIX. AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO ZERO
SIX PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. VOTE TO LINE. THIRTY ONE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRUM AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION U.
S. B. INTERFERENCE IN FEEDBACK
THEY MIGHT COMMITTEE THIS IS
VERY DISCONCERTING I'M I'M JUST
TELL US THE BILL NUMBER OR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE
ON. WE ARE LOWER L. SECURE THIS
TIME SIR ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFER
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO OH SIX-
SEEING O HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO OH SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO. MISTER
CORTESE'S TO BILLS SB TWO
THIRTEEN ON WORKERS COMP
AFFLUENT PLEASE. THE AUTHOR HAS
WAY PRESENTATION AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WE WILL NOW
MOVE AND IT IS NOT YOU KNOW HOW
WORKERS COMP HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES
SB TWO THIRTEEN WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. AND I SEE NO
ONE IS FORTY TWO OH THREE HERE
TO TESTIFY I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MISS MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. HERE
TO TESTIFY IN. SUPPORT OF SB
TWO THIRTEEN. TO IN SUPPORT. OF
SB TWO THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
HELLO AND LYFT. FOURTEEN ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEW YORKERS PLAINTIFF OPERATORS
ASSOCIATION THE PROFS WANT YOUR
S. B. THE ONE THREE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
TO GIVE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIRMAN BUT PLACE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO THIRTEEN-
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FIFTH- TO BE FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
COME UP ANY OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWO THIRTEEN. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
NECTAR OF THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
INCLUDING A MISTER TURNED ME
YOU MAY GO AT ALL RIGHT HAVING
OFF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION IN SB
TWO THIRTEEN. HOUSING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO
THIRTEEN WITHOUT ASSISTANCE
MOVING SB THREE HUNDRED.
SENATOR CORTESE ON CRIMES AND
MURDER AND PUNISHMENT- THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND MR
CORTESE'S WAY PRESENTATION.
BEFORE WE MOVED TO THE PUBLIC I
WANT TO REITERATE THAT WE WILL
BE INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT ON
WITNESS TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED THREE MINUTES
OF TOTAL TIME FOR PRIMARY
TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS. WISHING
TO TESTIMONY TESTIFIED. MOST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL WE ARE HEARING.
THIS ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY WILL
BE LIMITED TO TWELVE MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE. SO WOULD BE A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY THE THREE MINUTES OF
PRIMARY. PLUS TWELVE MINUTES OF
ME TOOS. SO THAT IS GOING TO DO
ON THIS BILL AS A REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. OF S. B. THREE HUNDRED
BY MISTER CORTESE AND AGAIN HIS
WAY PRESENTATION. SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THREE HUNDRED. THING NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
HUNDRED MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
PROP THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. ON THE TELECONFERENCE
MINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. THREE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
HUNDRED PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HELLO TO LINE
FOURTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IS BUYING
THE CAR SINCE YOU CAN AND HOPE
FOR THE BEST. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
HUNDRED BY MISTER CORTESE- WELL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING FOR
OPPOSITION I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY I SIX TO ME IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE C. NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP US
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE HUNDRED
AT THIS TIME- SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS. ONE THEN THE GIRL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
SHOOTING UP AT THIS TIME.
WONDERFUL HOW ABOUT THAT OKAY
HAVING OFF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SB
THREE HUNDRED. COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THERE'S NO HANDS
GOING UP. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE IN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE HUNDRED WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING S. B. TWO
FORTY BY SENATOR EGGMAN ON
INCOME TAX CREDITS. FOR FOOD
BANKS- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC HEARING ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN MAY TWO FOUR OH FIVE
SENATOR EGGMAN MISSES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO FOUR ZERO. AND IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IS P. TWO FOUR ZERO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WELL
NUMBER TOP POSITION OF SB TWO
FORTY- SINGLE IN A ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE SING NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MOST MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
SWITCHING TO OPPOSE SB TWO FOUR
ZERO. AND IF YOU'RE OPPOSING S.
B. TWO FOUR ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SP CHIU
FORTY. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB THREE TWENTY FIVE
SENATOR EGGMAN ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROTECTION ORDERS. THE
OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION. WE'LL
WRITE THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWO ZERO.
SIX NO ONE IN THIS ROOM-
SUPPORTING SB THREE TWO ZERO
SEEING NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. S. MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT TESTIMONY
FOR SB THREE TWENTY. IF THERE
IS ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWENTY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
IN QUEUED UP YOU MAY PROCEED
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION SB THREE TWENTY.
SAYING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE TO
OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY. TWO
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY S.
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. OF ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY. IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWENTY.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TWENTY. WE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND SEEING NO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE TWENTY. WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE BILLING ON SB
SIX NINETY NINE BY CENTERING ON
SCHOOL CLIMATE STATEWIDE SCHOOL
CLIMATE INDICATORS. IT'S A
SURVEY- THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY TO OPEN IN.
OF SB SIX NINETY NINE. AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FOUR TWO
OH THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP THE
SUPPORT. FOR SB. SIX NINE NINE.
IF YOU WERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SIX NINE NINE PRESS
ONE THE. WE HAVE KNOWN KID UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOT GO TO OPPOSITION SB SIX
NINE NINE THING NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. THING NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISS
MODERATOR PLEASE PICK UP ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION SB SIX NINE NINE.
AND IF YOU'RE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AT. EFFECT NINE.
ONE THERE THEN ZERO TWO IT'S
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION AND SB SIX NINE
NINE. AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX NINE NINE WILL
GO TO HIS FANS. WILL MOVE TO
SENATOR NEWMAN. SB TWO FOUR TWO
ONE HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENTS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AND
OPEN UP FOR SUPPORT. OF S. B.
TWO FOUR TWO. AND SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO SUPPORT S.
B. TWO FOUR TWO. THE NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY FOR A MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINE THIS MODERATOR
PLEASE GO UP ANY SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY ENDS SO IN FAVOR OF
SB TWO FOUR TWO. THANK YOU IT
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO FOUR
TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN DOING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT. WE WOULD OPPOSITION.
OF SB TWO FORTY TO. SEE NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. THING
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MOST MODERATOR PLEASE CUP
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SB TWO
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
YOU. FORTY TWO ONE ZERO THREE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN KNOWN AS
KEEPING UP WITH A POSITION. ARE
I HAVEN'T TAKEN THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY AND
SEEING NO HANDS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWO FOUR TWO.
IS MOVED TO SUSPEND. MOVING TO
SB TWO FIFTY BY DOCTOR PAN ON
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE- DR
PANDA'S WAVES. PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS ALSO A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE OF A RIGHT INTO
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO FIFTY. THING NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SING
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. S.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO FIFTY.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. GERMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FIFTY ON
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE ANYONE
OPPOSED TO SP TWO FIFTY SEEING
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE SING NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WHICH MODERATE PLEASE
GIVE UP ANY OPPOSITION TO SB.
TWO FIFTY. WHEN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FIFTY
PRESS ONE THEN. WE DO HAVE A
LINE CHEWING UP ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE TO THE
DEADLINE NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIFTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MY NAME IS ANDREA HAS
TERM AND I'M AGAINST ANYTHING
BY DICK POUND. THANK YOU.
BEYOND THIS DO PEOPLE OF THIS
PRESS. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE INTO
IT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKING D. BOTH SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND S.
B. TWO FIFTY IN SAYING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. C. TWO
FIFTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. I
WILL MOVE TO S. B. TWO FIFTY
TWO BY SENATOR WIENER ON
TOXICOLOGY TOXICOLOGICAL
TESTING ON DOGS AND CATS- THIS
IS A SUSPENSE ITEM IN THE
AUTHORS WEI PRESENTATIONS THE
MOVE RIGHT INTO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO FIFTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM. OF FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THIRTY ONE ON THE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO FIFTY TWO. IN TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
FIFTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIRMAN ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO A POSITION
OF S. B. TWO FIFTY TWO- SAYING
NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
SING NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
TWO FIVE TWO. IT IS BIG IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FIVE TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE NINE
GIVING UP ON MOMENT BY PREVENT
THEM THE NUMBER. GOOD LINE
FORTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR SENATORS
HELLO ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION WE
ARE PERSONALIZED AMENDED ON SB
TWO FIVE TWO THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
TO TWO FIVE TWO. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHTS HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ON S. B. TWO FIVE TO
SEE NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWO FIVE TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. BERMAN S.
B. TWO SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
ARCHER LETTER ON PARKS AND
RECREATION- THE LOWER SINGH
GAVE A ROW SAYING GABRIEL
RIVER- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION OF A RITE AID TO
SUPPORT- IS THERE ANYONE HERE
NO NO ONE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF ANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY MUCH
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWO SIXTY EIGHT. IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING BECAUSE KIDNEY FAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF DOWNEY
INTO COURT THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WOULD OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED. SB. TWO SIXTY
EIGHT. SPEAKING OPPOSITION TO
S. B. TWO SIXTY A PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SIXTY
EIGHT. I'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THERE'S NO HANDS
GOING UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT IS MOST OF
THE SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING TO SB
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
LEYVA ON PERS DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION BENEFITTED CHEST
PAINS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE NEW YORKERS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT
INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTIES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT. I HAD TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SEVEN
EIGHT PRESS ONE MILLION ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO INCLUDED
MISTER CHAIRMAN. ALL RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION OF SP TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT IS THERE ARE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED S. B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT- SIR NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY AT MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF SB. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION EVENTS
DEPICTED AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ON
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT SIGNAL CANCEL
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO SB THREE
TEN BY SENATOR RUBIO ON YET
UNUSED MEDICATION AND CANCER
MEDICAL RECYCLING THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SENATOR
RUBIO HAS WAVE PRESENTATION. OF
A RIDE INTO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TEN. THING
NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
SAYING NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
KEEP UP THE SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE TEN. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TEN PART
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL LINES
QUEUED UP AT THIS MOMENT- ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH A LINE OF. MISTER
MODERATOR THERE MAYBE FOR THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT TO ME FOR TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT I THINK THERE
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ONE OR TWO
PEOPLE FOR TWO SEVENTY EIGHT.
THIS CANCER- WILL C. WILL FIRST
GO TO LINE SIXTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THIS MORNING KAREN
NUMBERS PRESS FORTY DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN FACT THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU WHICH BILL- PARTY SB
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. OKAY THAT'S
WHAT I THOUGHT. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. SAN GABRIEL. THE NINE
BUT MOVED TO LINE FIFTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE ALTAMONT
INTERNET WITH THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY CANCER ACTION
NETWORK OUT THERE AND SB THREE
TEN THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE- ABOVE BOTTOM LINE IN Q.
THE RATE NEED TO PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER. PARDON ME WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE ELSE INTO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TEN
SENATOR RUBIO NOW'S THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE OPPOSED
SB THREE TEND TO SPEAK. THING
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
SING OF ANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
S. OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB. THREE TEN. IT IS
BEAON OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU'RE
PREVIOUSLY QUEUED UP A PRIVATE
PRIOR TO ME ANNOUNCING THIS
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN SHOOTING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SB THREE TENSING NO
HANDSOME MY COLLEAGUES GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
TENNIS THE SUSPENSE. FILE
MOVING TO SEE SB THREE FIFTEEN
BY SENATOR ROTH ON REBEKAH
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEEDS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND THE GENERAL IS
WAY PRESENTATION. SO WE WILL
MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIFTEEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SOMEBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY FOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTEEN BY GENERAL ROCK. AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN COMING
UP. ALL RIGHT NOW IT'S MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTEEN
IF SOMEBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE DAYS NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE
FIFTEEN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE FIFTEEN PRESS ONE BUT-
I. WE HAVE THE ONLINE STUDENT
MISTER SHERMAN GO AHEAD PLEASE
ALL RIGHT HAVING UP THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTEEN.
N. SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS THE THREE
FIFTEEN IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE. MOVING SB THREE FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR ALAN ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVERTISING
RECYCLING SYMBOL- HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION IN THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT TO SUPPORT AND SEEING NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
THREE C. NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY THREE MISTER MODERATOR HE
CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE
PRESS B. THREE FORTY THREE
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FORTY THREE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
FISHERMEN WE HAVE THE ONE ELSE
COMING UP. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FORTY
THREE. SAYING NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SAYING NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WHICH
MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION SB
THREE FORTY THREE. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE FORTY THREE PRESS ON.
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT PLEASE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FORTY THREE THING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE FORTY THREE HOPE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ASK THREE SEVENTY ONE
SENATOR CAVIAR- HAS ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE BILLS. HIS WAY
PRESENTATION SB THREE SEVENTY
ONE WHICH DEALS WITH HEALTH
INFORMATION AND TECHNOLOGY.
WILL MOVE RIGHT TO ASSIST THE
SUSPENSE CAN IT WILL MOVE RIGHT
TO TEST MONEY TO SUPPORT. IN
NOBODY FORTY TWO OH THREE
SINGLE BODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISS MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVED OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE SAYING NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THIS MODERATE PLEASE CUP ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION SB. THREE SEVENTY
ONE. SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SEVENTY ONE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE SEE
NO INTO THIS TIMES MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU MAY BE SEATED ALL
RIGHT HAVE A TAKE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES.
AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
SEVENTY ONE WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. LEVINE SB THREE
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR COUNTY
ERA ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING A
RESTRAINING ORDER THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND THEY
OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY TWO.
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SIX MODERATE PLEASE
QUEUE UP SUPPORT. FOR SB THREE
EIGHTY TWO. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE EIGHTY TWO PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
ARE GOING TO THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE COMPOSITION SB
THREE EIGHTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY MOST MODERATE PLEASE SKIP
THE OPPOSITION AND SB THREE
EIGHTY TWO. AND SPEAKING
OPPOSITION MSPS CREATED TO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE ARE GOING TO AT THIS
TIME MISTER SHERMAN ALL RIGHTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES
SENSING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE EIGHTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. HONESTLY
FOR SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
KABIRU ON SOCIAL INNOVATION
FINANCING PROGRAMS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE KENNEDY IN THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. OF A RIGHT
INTO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR SEVENTY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- SPIDERY
PLEASE SKIP ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FOUR SEVEN TWO. IS
BEACON SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN
TWO PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE HAVE NO
INCLUDE UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
SHERMAN WHAT OPPOSITION- SING
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
OPPOSED THIS BEFORE SEVENTY TWO
SAYING NOBODY IN. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED TO FOUR SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SP
FOUR SEVEN TWO. IT IS SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF SP FOUR SEVEN TWO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFERS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
OF MY COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS G. FOUR SEVEN C.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
SB FIVE THIRTY TWO. SENATOR
CARRIER ON PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
HIGH SCHOOL COURSEWORK AND
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
EXEMPTIONS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE IN THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT INTO
SUPPORT SB FOUR IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
THREE TWO THERE'S NO ONE HERE.
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
THREE TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION SB FIVE THIRTY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THIS MODERATOR
PLEASE PICK UP OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU THE
STATE OPPOSITION MSPS BY THREE
TWO NOW YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. KERN ONLINE
SECURITIES TIME. I HAVE A
OFFERED TO SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND
SEEING NO HANDS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES TO GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE THIRTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE
ON TO SB SIX TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR KABIRU ON COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT INTO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
FORTY. IST MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT. FOR SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE. THE STATE
SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY FIVE.
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THE ONE THAT. ALL.
INTERNAL LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE THING NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SING
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO IT SB.
SIX TWENTY FIVE. STATE
OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE. ZERO
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HERE HEARD THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THE S. B.
FOUR OH SIX FIVE SENATORS STERN
ON OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS
NOTICE OF INTENT INVESTIGATIONS
AND DATA AVAILABILITY THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND SENATOR
STARTERS WAY PRESENTATION WITH
THE RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT. IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH SIX THING
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THING NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISSED MODERATOR PLEASE
KILL ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH SIX BY
SENATOR STERN. THE STATE'S
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOR THE- YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO
ONE ZERO NINE. AN ONLINE TO.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR OH SIX THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOTHING FUNNY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
OPPOSITION SB FOUR OF SIX IS
THERE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME. TO STATE OPPOSITION
TO SB FOUR OH SIX THREE PRESS.
ONE THEN ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE DO ONLINE IN Q.
INCLINED FORTY TWO FOUR TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
ACREE LERI WITH A LUNCHEON.
CONTROL IN THIS LOCATION- WILL
POWER TAKEN OPPOSED TO MARK
AMENDED AT THE- FOUR OH SIX
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT HAVING
OFFERED THE BOTH PRO AND CON ON
SP FOUR OH SIX SYNCING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
BEFORE- SIX WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE. FILE MOVING ON THIS
B. FOR THIRTY BY SEVEN BORDERS-
THIS IS ON SMALL BUSINESS
REDUCTION OR WAIVER OF CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR VIOLATION OF
REGULATORY STATUTES SISI'S
CANDIDATE AND IT IS- HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT INTO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
THIRTY AND I SEE WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS MCKAY ON BEHALF
OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE
ELSE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE WE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING THAT ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISS MODERATOR PLEASE
KILL ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR THREE ZERO. TO SUPPORT SB
FOUR THREE ZERO NGUYEN PRESS.
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE THERE. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION SP FOUR
THREE ZERO SEE NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO FOUR THIRTY
THING NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED BEFORE THIRTY- WE WILL
GO TO. THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE SKIP ANYONE
OPPOSED SB FOUR THIRTY FEES FOR
YEAR ROUND AFTER REGULATION
THANK YOU TO STATE OPPOSITION
TO S. B. FOUR THREE ZERO PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE.
I'M GONNA LINE FOURTEEN ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS
CURRENT PLAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATE NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION IN COURT THIRTY
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES INTO Q. ALL RIGHT HAVING
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
THIRTY INCHING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS BEFORE
THIRTY WILL GO TO THE SUSPENSE.
WHILE MOVING ON THIS BEFORE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR LAYERED
ON REDEVELOPMENT AND CITY OF
ASK ACTORS COULD HOW DO YOU SEE
THIS TOWN TO ASK YOUR LAST
ATASCADERO ATASCADERO. MISTER
LEONARD IS WAY PRESENTATION OF
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE A
STATEMENT YOU WANT TO DO IT NOW
OR AT THE END. EVERYONE ELSE
OKAYFANTASTIC- SO WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR WHICH- SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT AND THERE'S
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. AND WILL
GO TO FOR TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSE SUPPORTING OF SB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. STATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL NGUYEN
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO THREE.
WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. YES I THINK WE
HAD THE MAYOR HEATHER MARINO
WAS GONNA BE QUEUED UP. BLIND
TWENTY TWO ZERO POINT TWENTY TO
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS DEBBIE
ARNOLD DAMAGED UNLESS IT IS THE
COUNTY FIFTH DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR I WENT A MEMBER OF
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. THAT
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED REPAYMENT
OF THE ART RT A LOAN AND I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT AND SB. FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU KNOW
OTHER LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION AND
OBVIOUSLY IF THE MAYOR JOINS US
PLEASE LET US KNOW WHAT
OPPOSITION AS BEFORE THIRTY
EIGHT. THE NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SAYING NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED- MR MURRAY
PLEASE SKIP ANYONE OPPOSES
BEFORE. THREE EIGHT. DESPITE
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR THREE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE
ZERO IS. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
TO OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT MISTER
LEONARD WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
A STATEMENT YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. I JUST WANT
TO DO TWO QUICK THINGS AND ONE
IS. FOR THOSE THAT DON'T KNOW
THIS IS ABOUT LOANS THAT WERE
MADE FROM THE CITY OF
ATASCADERO TO THE REDEVELOPMENT
DISTRICT THE BEGINNING. OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT DISTRICT THAT
WERE SWEPT WITH ALLOWED. OUT
BEING ALLOWED TO BE PAID BACK
AT THE TIME REDEVELOPMENT RIGHT
AWAY AND IT'S DIFFERENT THAN A
LOT OF THE OTHER REDEVELOPMENT
BILLS. AND THEY ACTED IN GOOD
FAITH WITH RESOLUTIONS LOAN
AGREEMENTS ADOPTED BUDGETS AND
EVEN AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND TEN
CASH PAYMENTS ON EAST EACH OF
THE THREE LOANS. THE POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS THE ANALYSIS
RAISED AN ISSUE. THAT SOMEHOW
THIS WASN'T DONE IN THE FIRST
TWO YEARS- AFTER THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY WAS PASSED
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT TO BE
CORRECT AND SO WHAT I WANT TO
DO IS MAKE SURE THAT THE CITY
WORKS WITH THE STAFF. AND
CLARIFIES THAT ISSUE IT WAS
ONE. OF A LOAN WAS ISSUED IN
THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
OTHERS I THINK WORK KNOWLEDGE
TO ANOTHER. JURISDICTION SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THAT IS RESOLVED BECAUSE- I'D
LIKE TO JUST GET THIS ISSUE
RESOLVED. SO I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT TO- HI WAS ALLOWED TO
MAKE. I WANT. WASTE
PRESENTATION ABOUT SLOW DOWN
THE MEETINGS AND WE'LL JUST
LOOK FORWARD TO DID FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MR
LAYERED AND OBVIOUSLY WELL IT'S
ON SUSPEND SHE'LL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I SAW MARK.
TAKE DILIGENT NOTES SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR- SEEING NO
OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS ON SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FOUR THIRTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. LEVINE THIS
BEFORE FOUR FOUR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ON PERSONAL INCOME
TAX SINCE COLLISIONS FROM GROSS
INCOME. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND HE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION. WE WILL GO RIGHT
TO. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
S. B. FOUR FOUR FOUR. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE YEARS HOW MANY ROOMS
TWENTY FORTY. MISTER MODERATORS
OR ANY SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE FOR S. TWO OF SHIMMY FOUR
FOUR FOUR. TO STATE SUPPORT
PRESS BEFORE FOR FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. ARE I TELL
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR FOUR
FOUR THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO FOR SURE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO WAS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED TO S. B. FOUR FOUR
FOUR. THE STATE OPPOSITION SB
FOUR FOUR FOUR. PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS BEFORE FOR
CHINO HANDS LEFT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE
ZERO TWO SIX PACKS. MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI HAS THREE BILLS EACH WAY
PRESENTATION ON ALL THREE WE'RE
GONNA GO RIGHT TO SB FIVE A ONE
ON CLAIMS AGAINST PUBLIC
ENTITIES THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SEEING NO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE A ONE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE. IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE A
ONE MISTER MODERATOR FIFTY Q.
OF ANY SUPPORT. FOR SB FIVE OH
ONE. TO SUPPORT SB FIVE A ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO PULL. ONE
OF BY ZERO. HE. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WOULD
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH ONE
NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
OPPOSITION SB FIVE A ONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE SEVEN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATOR- PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE OH
ONE. TO STATE OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE A ONE. WE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE.
NO NINE TO YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES FOR SB
FIVE OH ONE AND SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
OH ONE. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE CAN HAZARDOUS WASTE.
TREATED WOOD WASTE THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATA SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FIVE SEVEN SEE NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. IN OF ANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WHICH MODERATE
COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE SEVEN NOW WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO SUPPORT S. B.
FIVE FIVE SEVEN THAT'S. ONE
ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES AND
BILL ALL RIGHT WHAT OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE FIVE SEVEN- NOW IS
THE OPPORTUNITY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP UP THE
OPPOSITION. SB FIVE FIVE SEVEN.
THE STATE OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN THE BILL'S SB
FIVE BY. SEVEN PRESS ONE PAUL
THERE ALL. TURN ONLINE TO KEEP.
ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SPORT NOT POSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FIVE FIVE SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO SB EIGHT OH
SEVEN BY SEVEN THE WACHOWSKI ON
ENFORCEMENT OF CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION. OF A RIGHT TO
SUPPORT TESTIMONY ON SB EIGHT
OH SEVEN THING NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE
SAYING NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISS MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
THE SUPPORT TESTIMONY FOR SB
EIGHT OH SEVEN. TO SUPPORT S.
B. B. O. SEVEN. S. ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE ZERO PLEASE. TURN
ONLINE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE TO A POSITION OF SB
EIGHT OF SEVEN SAYING NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
EIGHT OH SEVENTEEN OPENING ROOM
TWENTY FORTY S. MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. POST SB EIGHT OH
SEVEN. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TWO
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH SEVEN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT HAVING
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP FROM MY
COLLEAGUESWITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT OH SEVEN IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE FILE. SENATOR JONES
HAS OUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS SB
FIVE THIRTY FOUR ON DENTAL
HYGIENIST THIS IS A BILL
ELIGIBLE FOR DO PASS MOTION AND
SENATOR JONES- WILL MAKE A
PRESENTATION AND I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE TO PRIMARY WITNESSES
ON THE COASTLINE- ANTHONY LA
LA- THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD AND
JENNIFER. CANNAVALE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION SO MISTER JONES
TELL US ABOUT SB FIVE THREE
FOUR OBVIOUSLY FOCUS ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT. THANK YOU MISTER
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR
DAYS TO DENTAL HYGIENE PRACTICE
ACTS ACT INCLUDING INCREASING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BY
ESTABLISHING. INSPECTIONS FOR
REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST IN
ALTERNATIVE PRACTICE THIS BILL
HAS A MINOR COSTS RESULTING
FROM ONE NEW STAFFING POSITION.
AS MENTIONED WE HAVE- TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ON THE LINE READY TO TALK
TO US. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
WILL GO TO MISTER LAMB AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM. MISS TENET
HEALTH FOR A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES FOR BOTH OF THEM PLEASE
TAKE IT AWAY. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M ANTHONY LUND EXECUTIVE UP
THE DENTAL HYGIENE FOR
CALIFORNIA. WHAT IS ONE OF THE
MANY NATIONAL LICENSING BOARD
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
WE CONTINUALLY REVIEW AND
ANALYZE A LAWS AND PROPOSED NEW
LEGISLATION OR AMEND EXISTING
LEGISLATION FOR IMPROVEMENTS
UPDATE AND CLARITY THE COMPLETE
THE BOARD'S MISSION. THE
PROPOSED BUDGETARY LANGUAGE IN
SENATE BILL FIVE REPORT IS
ACCUMULATIVE. OF WORK OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS TO ADDRESS
VERY SUPPORT ISSUES. FROM
ADDITIONAL BOARD MEMBER TERM
STAGGERING MAINTAIN QUORUM FOR
MEETINGS THE OVERSIGHT THE
MOBILE DENTAL HYGIENE CLINICS
TO ENHANCE ACCESS TO DENTAL
HYGIENE CARE FOR VULNERABLE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
ASSISTING LICENSING ON
PROBATION WHICH REMEDIAL
EDUCATION IF WARRANTED. IT
PROVISIONS ONE HALF BOARDS
BILITY TO CONDUCTING BUSINESS
AND PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE
DENTAL HYGIENE PROFESSION AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION. FISCAL IMPACT
PRESENTED BY SB FIVE THIRTY
FOUR IS THE RESULT OF THE NEW
OVERSIGHT WORKLOAD FOR THE
MOBILE DENTAL HYGIENE CLINIC.
MODEL HEIDI CLINICS WILL
PROVIDE BETTER ACCESS TO DENTAL
CARE ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO
CAN'T TRAVEL TO DOUBLE UP WITH
THE- THESE ARE. MOBILE DENTAL
HIGH CLINICS FOCUS ON THE
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. AND
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY FOR DENTAL
HYGIENE CARE ISN'T READILY
AVAILABLE THE REQUESTED FUNDING
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF WILL WORK
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING FOR
OPERATING IN THE STATE
APPROPRIATE MANNER. YOU CAN
CLEAN EQUIPMENT IMPROPERLY
STERILIZED DENTAL TOOLS FOR
INFECTION CONTROL TO PROVIDE
THEIR DENTAL HYGIENE SERVICES
TO THE CONSUMER. I THANK CENTER
JONES AND THE CALIFORNIA DON'T
I. YOU FOR SPONSORING AND CO
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION TO
BOARD AND INSPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR APPROVAL OF FUNDING FOR SB
FIVE THREE FOUR I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS. FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO YOUR SECOND WITNESS- MISS
TAMIL. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
CAN I HELP WITH AARON RED AN
ASSOCIATE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION. WORKING WITH THE
DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PLEASED TO
HAVE AGREED ON A LARGELY
TECHNICAL AND CLEAN UP ITEMS IN
SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR. THESE
ITEMS IMPROVED PORT OPERATIONS
TO BENEFIT LIKE INDEED AND
CLARIFIED THE BOARD'S AUTHORITY
TO OVERSEE MOBILE CLINICS ALL
SUPPORTING THE BOARD YOUR
PROTECTION EFFORTS FOR A LOW
COST. WE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATED COULD GO TO THE PHONE
LINE AND OPEN UP TESTIMONY WILL
IT SEE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT. OF SB
FIVE THIRTY FOUR. THE SPEAKER
BORDER THAT'S FIVE FOUR THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
IF OF THE FLAT ALL RIGHT WE
WERE GONNA GO TO OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE THIRTY FORCING NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSING COMPANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY- MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP THE
OPPOSITION TO SB. FIVE THREE
FOUR. SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE REPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ARGUED UP YOU MAY PROCEED.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION MR JONES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
WITNESSES ASKED FOR MY VOTE
PLEASE. MISTER LEONARD HAS
ACKERMAN I'M SORRY I MISSED IT
OKAY IT'S CONSISTENT WITH WHAT.
HE JUST SAID- BECAUSE I WAS
GOING TO SAY THAT. IF THE SINCE
I FINALLY HAVE A FEW THINGS IN
MY OFFICE I HAVE A LITTLE PICK
ON A PEDESTAL THAT WAS THE
FIRST CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION GLUTTON FOR
PUNISHMENT AWARD. BECAUSE I DID
A BUILT ON DENTAL HYGIENE THAT
WAS OF JANICE AND I THINK THAT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS JUST
CLARIFIED THAT THERE SOMETHING
NEEDED IN STATUTE THAT DOESN'T
EXIST TO DO WHAT AND I THINK
IT'S GREAT AND I MOVED THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER LATER
FOR THOSE COMMENTS IN THE
MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB
FIVE THREE FOUR MR- YOU YOU
SHOULD CONSULT. WITH YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SAN BILL FIVE
THREE FOUR WITH MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO I.
PORTANTINO HI BATES. BATES FIVE
BRADFORD BRADFORD FIVE JONES
JONES ARE CALM LONGER LAYERED
BY LAYERED HI MY COUNTY HI
CASKEY ARE A SIX OF THOSE OUT
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR.
FAR LONGER. AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT. BILL WHICH IS SB
SIX OH SIX- GONZALEZ ON
WORKFORCE SAFETY. AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE- AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO WITNESSES
THE SON WORK FOR SAFETY
VIOLATIONS OF STATUTES
ENTERPRISE VIOLATIONS AND
EMPLOYER RETALIATION WILL GO TO
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH SIX.
SEEING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
GOING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SAYING NO ONE THERE. WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX OH SIX. AND
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX. SIX
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HELLO KEIRA MISTER. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX OF SIXTEEN NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM SING ANY KNOWN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE- IN
OPPOSITION SB. SIX OH SIX. IT
IS BEACON OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE SOME CHEWING UP IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH
THEIR NOT LIE NUMBER. THAT
PERSON TOOK THEMSELVES OUT OF
QUEUE. YOU MAY PROCEED. ALL WE
HAVE TO OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX SIX SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITH MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX OF SIX WHO
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING SB SIX SIX SIX BY
SENATOR ON BERGEN ELECTRONIC
SERVICE OF PAPER BY COURT- THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
CENTERS WAY PRESENTATION. OF A
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SIX SIX. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NO ONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT SB. SIX SIX
SIX. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SIX. PRESS ONE IN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO INCLUDING
UP YOU MAY BE SEATED MISTER
CHAIRMAN ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFER
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION NOW
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE OPPOSED TO SIX SIX
SIX. THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
SIX SIX SIX. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SB
SIX SIX SIX- TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX SIX
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IT'S A TERRIBLE
CANNABINOID QUEUED UP IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT HAVING OFF
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SB SIX
SIX SIX AND SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX SIX
SIX. IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE MOVING SB SIX EIGHTY FOUR
BY SENATOR HUESO ON THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER COMMISSION
SUSPENDS CANADA CENTERS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE'RE SEEING
IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHTY FOUR
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE ARE NONE. NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE STOP ANY SUPPORT. FOR SB.
SIX EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HUESO. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF STE SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP PLEASE
PROCEED ALL RIGHT WE'RE
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR- THING NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO S. B. SIX EIGHTY
FORCING NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THIS MODERATE PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE FOR ANY
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB. SIX EIGHTY FOUR. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION MSPS
DICTATED POOR PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT TO GET
RESERVE GERMAN WE HAVE NO IN IN
Q. ALL RIGHT HAVE A OP THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF S. B. SIX
EIGHTY PORTANTINO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR WITHOUT SUSPENSE. BILLION
SB SEVEN TEN BY SENATOR
BRADFORD ON DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
CONFLICT OF INTEREST THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
GO RIGHT INTO TESTIMONY OF
SUPPORT. ON SB SEVEN TEN AND I
SEE WE HAVE ONE PERSON IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE PLEASE. TELL
US ABOUT SB SEVEN TEN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH
ON BEHALF OF GOVERNMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE
ISFORTY TWO OH THREE. SINGLE
IN A ROOM TWENTY FORTY THIS
MODERATE PLEASE GIVE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN TEN. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO DESPITE.
BILL CLINTON Q. MISTER CHAIRMAN
PLEASE VISIT ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOT OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TEN
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE OPPOSED TO SEVEN TEN.
FEMALE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED TO SEVEN TEN MR MURRAY
PLEASE GIVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB SEVEN TEN.
THANK YOU LIVE YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO IN QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
BOTH PORT OPPOSITION WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. AND SING
THEIR HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN TEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVIES SB SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BRADFORD ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION RISK FACTORS THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WITH A RITE AID PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. THING NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM. SUPPORTING SB
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT SAYING
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SUPPORTING SB EIGHTY EIGHT.
THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. YOU KNOW MY- RIGHT.
THIS MODERATE ISRAELI SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT.
PARDON ME IF WE- BUT IF YOU
WERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP IN SUPPORT I WOULD
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT MISSING THERE BUT IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED. SB SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THE SAME OVER THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED TO SEVENTY
EIGHT MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE. ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF THERE IS
ANYONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT. PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NO.
FOUR OR OPPOSITION- WE'VE
OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING SB SEVEN
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR MELENDEZ.
ON INTER SCALISE
INTERSCHOLASTIC ATHLETES AND WE
WILL SHE IS WAY PRESENTATION
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY TWO SEVEN
TWENTY TWO NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHICH MODERATE
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SWITCHING TO SUPPORT
SB SEVEN TWO TWO. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWO TWO. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WHO
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
WELL GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN TWENTY TWO S<c.cyan> NOBODY IN</c>
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE ANYBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SB. SEVEN TWENTY
TWO. IT IS BEACON OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO IT COULD OF THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT COMING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ON SEVEN TWENTY TWO
AND GETTING NONE. COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND THERE'S NO
HANDS GOING UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN TWENTY TWO
MOVES TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
MOVING TO SB SEVEN FORTY SIX
FIVE SENATORS SKINNER. ON
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
POLITICAL PURPOSES THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE IS
NONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE THERE
WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB SEVEN
FORTY SIX. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN FORTY SIX. ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
LINE YOU JUST ONE MOMENT. WE DO
HAVE A LINE IN Q. JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEIR INFORMATION. WE WILL GO
ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING THIS BRAND
FOR STALL REPRESENTING COMMON
SENSE AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN FORTY SIX. WE HAVE NO
NIELSEN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND THANK YOU
WILL GO TO THE OPPOSITION
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE OF ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS. MISTER
MOHAMMED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ON THE
COASTLINE AS A PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WE WILL
HEAR FROM MISTER MOHAMMED.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR COMMENTS
AND WE WILL LIMIT TO THREE
MINUTES FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES.
IS THERE. MISTER
MODERATOR DO YOU HAPPEN. I DO
NOT SHOW IS LINE CONNECTED. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON TO GENERAL
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION AND IF
HE SHOULD SHOW UP WHILE WE'RE
ON THE BILL WILL GIVE HIM THIS
OPPORTUNITY BUT- ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. SEVEN FORTY
SIX. THE RIVER. FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE.
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE QUEUED
UP FOR SB SEVEN FORTY SIX
OPPOSITION. YES IN ORDER TO
GIVE UP FOR SB FORTY SIX
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME SEVEN WE DO HAVE A
LINE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER. THE ONE
SPEAKING AT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE-
HELLO SIR I APOLOGIZE MY NAME'S
ALEX RETIRED I'M- FOR SURE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY I APOLOGIZE I MISSED.
SOME OUT BUT MY NUMBER TO GET
PICKED UP BUT I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. .ORG THANK.
I THANK YOU. BROWN OPPOSITION
EDITORS IT WAS SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO THIS TIME. THIS SHERMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP PLEASE
VISIT ALL RIGHT AND THERE'S NO
MISTER MUHAMMAD AS THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION LAST CALL.
HEARING NO THING FROM ANYONE-
WILL COME BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE'VE OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ON SB
SEVEN FORTY SIX. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN FORTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE OUR FINAL
BILL IS BY ME AT FORTINO
TRESPASS ON PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OUTWEIGH
PRESENTATION. VOTER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM. THERE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. S. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHICH
IN TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE- AND QUEUING
UP. IT MAY BE SEATED ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GET OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT. THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THERE'S NO
ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THESE
FIRST MODERATE TO OF ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SB. SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE LOAN QUEUED UP
ELECTRICITY ALL RIGHT HAVING
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT. SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT. POSTED
THE SUSPENSE FILE WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON CALL SB. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR JONES. MR
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON SB. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR. YES THIS IS SB
FIVE THIRTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR PALM
LONGER. KAMLAGER I HAVE SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT SEVEN ZERO I D NOT BELIEVE
WE HAVE ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS
CALL AND I BELIEVE WE'VE
COVERED ALL OF THE- OF THE DAY-
SO WE'VE OPENED THE ROLE WE'VE
DONE THAT- THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO'S PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO GET YOUR
TESTIMONY AND PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE ALL TESTIMONY. I THINK
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT A
TECHNICAL GLITCH IN THE MIDDLE
SO IF YOU MISSED YOUR CHANCE
PLEASE SEND IN YOUR WRITTEN
WRITTEN RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
PROTECT PRITCHETT EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
AS WE'RE DOING THE BEST WE CAN.
AND THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IS NOW. THIRD SHIRT.
THANK YOU BASIS.